[Music]
in the eighth episode of star trek
picard's second season guyan and q come
face to face and the board queen builds
up her new army and there's also a big
nod to an enterprise episode you may
have forgotten about
in episode 8 mercy rafi and 7 of 9 are
still trying to get a fix on the jarate
queen's location following her trail
leads to an alley where they find a man
dead of an apparent attempted
assimilation rafi in seven of nine
conclude that the geranti queen is
trying to create new borg soldiers in
the 21st century but doesn't have the
raw material to do so yet they managed
to locate the man's cell phone which is
missing its battery seven of nine notes
that the stabilizing metals of a
lithium-ion power source like a cell
phone battery are just what the jarrati
queen needs after all when the borg
assimilate their victims they inject
them with stabilizing metals to help the
body handle the invading borg nanoprobes
this reminds seven of nine of her own
assimilation i can still remember the
smell it was six
i can taste it now this directly
references the events seen during a
flashback in the star trek voyager
episode the raven in that flashback
viewers see a young seven of nine then
called annika hansen when she is first
assimilated while on her parents
exploratory mission to learn about the
board we see in that episode her parents
are first taken by the borg while young
annika runs to hide although her actual
assimilation is not shown on screen to
this day it seems that the traumatic
experience still has a deeply profound
effect on her
in mercy we get another direct reference
to the previous unresolved history
between guyan and q first teased in the
star trek the next generation episode
q-hoo that episode mentions a cold war
between el orions and q but here it
becomes clear that this period of
conflict was not when q met gainen when
q comes to visit her while disguised as
an fbi agent he seems surprised to see
her and even more confused when she
doesn't recognize him this is the first
meeting between q and gainen in more
than 30 years on screen and he makes a
remark that references their past
connection right
it's the 21st century
our paths have yet to cross this at
least gives trekkies a time frame to
work with because all we knew about
their history before this was that their
dealings together were more than 200
years before their meeting in cuhu which
is set in 2365. thanks to this new scene
fans can now narrow down their first
canonical encounter to somewhere between
2100 and 2165 given the way q is phrased
it here we still don't know quite what
happened at that meeting but perhaps
we'll get more answers as the season
winds toward the finish line
the biggest easter egg pound and the
latest meeting between q and gainen
comes with the revelation that the q are
dying turmoil in the q continuum is
nothing new and the scene appears to be
a direct callback to those events it all
begins in the star trek voyager season 2
episode death wish where a member of the
queue is discovered imprisoned on a
comet for the crime of desiring to end
his own life bored with his unending
existence the second q named quinn
wishes to cease to exist but the
continuum fears that the loss of his
life could create a catastrophic
disruption it would force the cue to
deal with the unknown for the first time
since the new era began they're afraid
of the unknown however q himself is not
afraid despite the continuum's wishes he
rebels and assists in quinn's suicide in
the season 3 episode the q in the gray
quinn's death causes ripple effects
through the continuum resulting in a
catastrophic q civil war one side wants
the stability and predictability of the
old ways while the other wants to
embrace change individuality and the
unknowable here q notes that his loss of
powers leaves him with an uncertain
future saying he is on the threshold of
the unknowable and seemingly delighted
to experience what is new and unknown
despite his impending demise a callback
to his decision to help quinn die in
death wish infinite life after all has
its drawbacks
in mercy we finally get a glimpse of a
scene from an early trailer that
features a pair of vulcans in the woods
with a young human boy here we learn
that the scene takes place some decades
earlier perhaps as early as the 1970s
when fbi agent wells was just a child
while looking for his dog the future
agent well stumbles upon a pair of
vulcans engaged in some form of
monitoring earth that earth had been
visited before by vulcans for covert
surveillance is not a new revelation as
it is first mentioned in the enterprise
episode carbon creek in that season 2
episode of enterprise we learned that
science officer depaul's foremother
tamir was on a vulcan ship that had been
monitoring earth in the 1950s tamir and
a small team wind up trapped on earth
after crash landing in carbon creek
pennsylvania and live undercover as
humans until they are rescued with tamir
posing as a young woman named maggie
depaul mentions in the episode that
tamir's visit was her people's first
contact with humanity now we see that
the vulcans undertook further missions
to observe human progress just as the
federation observes pre-warped societies
interestingly the young boy's dog is
named maggie which seems like another
intentional reference to a character
from trek past
when agent wells reveals his childhood
encounter with aliens we recognize them
as a pair of vulcans but the young human
boy in the 20th century sees only
strange inhuman beings he tries to run
but the vulcans follow him into the
woods before performing an alien ritual
to erase his memory and preserve the
secret to their meeting however it must
not have worked because wells remembers
everything about that evening including
the alien's attack which is how he
interprets what picard later identifies
as a vulcan mind meld wells describes
the mind meld as a vicious assault with
a feeling like the alien's fingers were
pushing into his head of course that was
not the case and picard describes more
accurately what the vulcan had done by
pressing his fingers gently onto the
agent's face in the traditional form
we've seen in several star trek episodes
before picard's knowledge of the mind
meld technique as performed by vulcans
such as spock tuvak and ceval come from
the star trek the next generation
episode sarik in which piccard is the
recipient of a mind meld demonstrated by
spock's father sarik we shall always
retain the best part of the other
inside us
first introduced in the star trek the
next generation second season episode
cue hoo the borg's black-clad cyborg
visage has become an iconic part to pop
culture their cube-like starships are as
oddly distinctive as any spacecraft in
science fiction and the two-part episode
the best of both worlds is the tv
classic the borg have several
catchphrases and memorable lines
associated with them perhaps most famous
is their chilling typical greeting line
resistance is futile we are the borg
blow your shields
this line is revisited here in mercy but
with a 21st century twist when the
draerati queen visits adams soon i
assume a lecture on the futility of
resistance is not going to be necessary
once adam soon has supplied her with
what she needs an army of highly trained
military soldiers the two prepare for a
mission in a sense these mercenaries are
earth's first board drones with the
geranti queen injecting them with borg
technology and changing them into her
own willing army who's in the mood to
add a little of their
biological and technological
distinctiveness to our own this echoes
the early speech that the board gave
picard as an ominous warning about their
intentions towards humanity well that is
the borg mission statement to absorb
other beings cultures and technology
adding everything unique and distinctive
about them to their collective whole
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you